un projet de loi de finances présenté
dans un contexte exceptionnel c'est par
ces mots que bruno le maire le ministre
de l'économie a débuté cette conférence
de presse qui a duré à peu près une demi
heure bruno le maire qui a confirmé
qu'il a volontairement fait des
prévisions plus prudentes que l' ocde et
la banque de france pour justement
anticiper une rechute de la situation
sanitaire alors que la colère gronde
parmi les restaurateurs le ministre de
l'économie a rappelé à la volonté du
gouvernement il s'agit dit il de
soutenir les salariés et les entreprises
touchées par la crise sanitaire à ce
propos il a confirmé de nouvelles aides
pour le secteur de la restauration qui
est particulièrement touché par la crise
sanitaire écoutez je sais que beaucoup
d'entre eux s'inquiètent sur les prêts
qu'ils ont consentis les prêts garantis
par l'état
il ya eu 120 milliards d'euros de prêts
garantis par l'état qui ont été
consentis dont 90% sont allés à des très
petites entreprises à des pme et dont
beaucoup dans le secteur du tourisme de
l'hôtellerie et de la restauration
beaucoup d'entre eux se demandent mais
comment est ce que nous allons faire si
nous aurons besoin de prolonger la durée
de ce prêt parce qu'on ne peut pas
rembourser tout de suite je vous ai
garantit des taux attractifs vous aurez
des taux attractifs
le fonds de solidarité qui a bénéficié à
1,7 million d'entreprises et qui a
représenté plus de 6 milliards d'euros
de dépenses publiques
nous allons aussi le renforcer et le
premier volet qui était plafonné à 1500
euros sera portée jusqu'à 10000 euros
pour les entreprises qui sont fermées
administrativement ou celles dont le
chiffre d'affaires aurait baissé de 80%
à cause de ces règles sanitaires
l exécutif qui maintient ses prévisions
budgétaires des prévisions qui restent
malgré tout très fragile car de
nombreuses incertitudes subsistent
d'abord avec ce plan de relance est ce
que finalement elle les dizaines de
milliards d'euros de ce plan seront
injectés assez rapidement pour relancer
l'économie
autre question il s'agit de la confiance
des ménages est ce que les foyers
français vont continuer à consommer
alors que le climat social se durcit à
ce propos bruno le maire promet d'ici
nous aurons je le cite baissé de 45
milliards d'euros les impôts pesant sur
les ménages et les entreprises nous
n'augmenterons pas les impôts alors le
mot clé de ce budget 2021 qui sera
présenté cet après midi devant
l'assemblée nationale on l'a bien
compris c'est la relance mais la reprise
de l'épidémie de kobe 19 risque de
menacer cette ambition gouvernementale
si un vaccin n'était pas trouvé pour
rassurer les entreprises mais aussi elle
les ménages français